was an inventor of hyperbolic
programming so he'll tell us about
first-order methods and hyperbolic
program right thank you go ahead and
event went easy on you because I am
going to hit you with a fire hose no
this is a really broad audience and so
I'm gonna start out with basics for
first-order methods then I'll walk
through some stuff which I actually
talked to Simon's here about five years
ago and which got developed afterwards
over time and then I'll be moving on and
sort of wrapping up with more recent
stuff but it all it all weaves together
so for the first part we'll look at just
first-order methods I'm just going to go
through it very quickly so we have a
function we're trying to minimize we
have a closed convex feasible region and
you know the most basic of the
first-order methods first of all I
should say for motivation first-order
methods you know they're a big deal
nowadays because they require so a
little storage you have a vector
typically that you have to store a
gradient vector you don't have a whole
Hessian matrix like you do with interior
point methods and you know there's a big
difference in storage when n is going
off to the millions with as opposed to N
squared a vector the the cost of solving
the equations with an interior point
method that's n cubed but it's not
really the n cube that's the bottleneck
because in the end the first order
methods take a lot more iterations so
they're very slow compared to an
interior point method in terms of
iterations that you can actually get the
computation done even when you move to
many many
okay so the most basic wrist order
methods and you see their shortcoming
already of course or this form XK that
you're current in turret GK is either a
gradient of F at XK or in the case that
F is not differentiable it'll be a sub
gradient and so sub gradients are
especially nice oftentimes they're very
easy to compute you can often have so if
you're not differentiable at a point
you'll have a whole set of sub gradients
and so you just need to choose one and
these algorithms the tricky part is
right here so it's just taking a descent
step and then what it's doing to handle
the constraints it's projecting onto the
feasible region okay and so this is
typical there are other first order
methods proximal methods which replace
orthogonal projection with a different
operation but still feasible regions
which have procs functions for which the
corresponding operation is readily
computable feasible regions cuher are
simple they have simple geometric
structure and so this is really the
shortcoming from you know the viewpoint
of math programming people it shouldn't
hyperbolic programming in particular you
know the feasible region is typically
not something that you can orthogonal
project on too easily you know this step
is is trivial but then the cost really
is doing the orthogonal projection so
unless your feasible region is empty
these these algorithms are a no-go at
least in this this okay so let me just
record the you know the basic results
for first order methods typically if
your function is differentiable you
assume it's what's called smooth and all
that saying is that the gradient map is
Lipschitz continuous so there exists a
constant hell eye algorithm that works
which you know from calculus is just
gradient descent and so with gradient
descent all you're doing is you're
choosing the step size I'll pick a up
there this is assuming you know a
Lipschitz constant or an upper bound on
the Lipschitz constant
there right now been anyway what you get
is that after a certain number of
iterations depending on your epsilon so
this is gonna be the desired accuracy
okay after a certain number of
iterations also depending on how far
your initial point is from the set of
optimal solutions and your Lipschitz
constant then you're guaranteed that
your iterance will satisfy they'll be
with an epsilon of optimality and so the
thing you know there's a lot of
different quantities not a lot but a few
quantity showing up here I'm going to
end this talk to keep things focused I'm
just gonna be looking at the epsilon
what's the dependence on epsilon that's
gradient descent can't let's do then
Nesterov accelerated method i'm not
going to go through Nesterov accelerated
method here it is generates two
sequences of points and it also has a
sequence of scalars it gets updated as
it goes along too as well which has the
sequence of scalars has nothing to do
with a particular set of points but
anyway so it is making a projection and
then it does something which is kind of
strange this is how it gets XK plus 1
then it updates the Y sequence with a
certain formula so we're not going to go
into that the point here though is in
terms of epsilon now you have 1 over
square root of epsilon rather than 1
over epsilon optimal you've already he
also gotten rid of a distance squared
down to distance but will not worry
about that okay and so the you know the
most elementary of the algorithms are
the sub gradient methods and so this is
when your function f is simply Lipschitz
itself so it doesn't have gradients now
it's not differentiable it'll be
different jumbled lots of places but
some places it won't be so we're going
to just Dennis you the typical
assumption is that it's it's Lipschitz
continuous on an open neighborhood of
the feasible region and so these are
these you would expect or such general
algorithms that they're gonna have bad
complexity bounds and what you get now
is with this particular step size so
it's going to depend on epsilon now
you wantyou you specified an accuracy
you want you want to get with an epsilon
of the optimal value and so using that
and the step size you're using up here
depends on the sub gradient you've
chosen you divide by the norm squared of
that and the epsilon for the so called
step size now sub gradient methods
they're not strict descent method you're
not guaranteed of getting a sequence of
interest function values that is
strictly decreasing when you apply a sub
gradient method the function values when
you watch them sometimes they start
going up for a while and then they start
going down again up and down in time
what happens is that after a certain
number of iterations you've made as you
make iterations you always keep track of
who is the best point you've been you've
seen so far and set that aside that's
your your your best your best point so
far and with them after you've taken
this many iterations you have you're
guaranteed to seen a point your best
point will indeed be within epsilon of
optimality so here now this is you know
this is where you really run into
problem it's 1 over epsilon squared
genny's so epsilon small you're taking
lots of iterations so compared with
accelerated method which apply to a
different class of problems the
differentiable smooth problems that was
a 1 over square root of epsilon so now 1
over epsilon squared says there's a huge
difference ok so there is the
so now okay so we're gonna somehow use
these to solve hyperbolic programs and
so first just set some notation the Vepr
is wrong I'm not gonna use gamma plus a
code this is a finite dimensional
Euclidean space think of it mean lots of
variables made so many variables that
you don't want to try to do an interior
point method in it you just storing the
Hessian is too much okay whenever you
talk about first order method there's
underlying or at least a great interest
some gradient method under there's
underlying a Euclidean inner product
because here you actually are
subtracting a gradient from a point that
points in the primal space the gradient
is an object in the dual space to be
able to subtract the gradient from the
thrival somehow you're having to
identify the two spaces together which
is when an inner product does for you it
says the dual space is the primal space
and the inner product also gives you
what the gradient is so you change the
inner product you change the gradient
for here you should just think of the
euclidean standard dot product it
doesn't matter
so we'll be fixing the inner product
it's going to be it's very much
different than interior point methods
where your interior your inner product
changes from iteration enter it is
essentially going on
so with first order methods your your
inner product becomes fixed - velocity
cone there's my hyperbolic polynomial
right so for any e within the interior
of the hypervelocity cone then I get
this function and lambda or any X and
the Euclidean space and the roots of
this give me what I call the eigenvalues
the eigenvalues of X okay and so we get
the roots of that so we're gonna fix our
e you can think of being the identity
matrix the N by n symmetric matrices
indefinite cone and in that case these
are just the the eigenvalues of X the
matrix X in that case
and so I often just say eigenvalues I
something that showed up on Levent slide
he's framed it slightly differently you
get a norm from this you just take the
maximum of the absolute value of the
eigenvalues and that gives you a norm on
your Euclidean space and to understand
the geometry of it if you look at the
unit ball centered at your fixed
direction II so I fix T Nashes and so
these are the roots once I fix these he
is now fixed it's the identity matrix
whatever you wanted to be it's fixed so
every X has these these roots
eigenvalues this thing gives you a norm
on the vectors X and this particular set
right here is the largest centrally
symmetric largest symmetric set
symmetric at a centrally symmetric at
ethat fits within the cone so it's what
was coming up on Levin slide when he was
filling out it's a uniball and okay and
so now okay so here comes our big player
the minimum eigen value eigen value or
the X this is a concave function in X
that's well-known bag.even and
gardening's paper was essentially there
so this is the function we're gonna be
focusing on can't you it and so get to
this in the next slide this is a nice
function it's actually Lipschitz
continuous and in terms of this
particular norm the Lipschitz constant
is one
but with with gradient methods some
gradient methods you have a inner
product you're working with and so when
you talk about distances it's with
respect to the inner product that's
defining the gradients and so this
particular the warm is not so natural in
the context of the first order methods
and so then once we take our Euclidean
norm then well it'll still be Lipschitz
continuous function but the Lipschitz
constant is is going to change if we
replace this with our Euclidean norm and
what it changes to it changes this
quantity right here this is the largest
Euclidean the radius of the largest
Euclidean ball centered at the point
either fits within the saw inside the
the with them inside the hyperbola
Siddiq okay okay so it's of course it's
still Lipschitz and so if it is what
this is saying that is that as your
point e gets closer to the boundary of
the cone then this minimum eigen value
function it's dependent on e this
minimum eigen value function the
Lipschitz constant becomes worse so
ideally you in defining choosing an e to
work with such a function as this
minimizing value function you'd like to
be as far away from the boundary as
possible constant here and that'll bring
also down then the complexity bounds on
the first order methods so now I need to
do a construction with this value which
we're going to use in the subsequent
slides
and so let's put in the hyperbola city
cone there it is and so there's the
point e we've chosen we fixed e it's in
the interior of the code so I want to
what we're gonna want to do is in a
first order methods we're gonna want to
replace the orthogonal projection with a
much easier operation we wanna get rid
of orthogonal projection we want
something that we can use in solving
even hyperbolic programs
we don't want to try to do orthogonal
projections on to the feasible region of
a hyperbolic program at every iteration
okay and so what's the construction
we're going to rely on there's my code
here's a point X and what I'm going to
do is I'm going to look at the line
segment half line beginning at E that
goes through X and I what I'm going to
use for projection is I'm gonna where it
intersects the boundary where it
intersects the boundary so given an X
then I'm gonna sociate with X this
particular point PI of X projection of X
I call it the radial the radial
projection of X and it's of course
determined by the e I fixed now of
course some points X if I chose X up
here and I took the line segment
beginning at E and continue through I'd
never hit the boundary so it's only you
only gonna hit the boundary for some
cases and so what this is saying is that
you'll hit it's not hard to see but
you'll hit the boundary if and only if
the smallest of the eigenvalues is less
than 1 at the point X and in that case
then you also get a formula for this
point this radial projection and down
here this is just coming from the
homogeneity of the hyperbolic polynomial
P you're laying and relying on that in a
simple way you get this formula and it's
dependent on the minimum eigen value
right there which again PI X this
projection exists only if this is less
than 1 and so you're not dividing by a
positive number there
so the way I think about it visually
radio projection if I'm at this point X
really what I'm doing is I'm moving
towards E and so it's a projection in
that sense in the same vein if I take
anything on this same line like over
here I do its projection it's going to
the same PI of X so everything on that
line through E gets projected so this is
the fundamental operation forests I give
you a point X computing that
intersection with the boundary okay so
that's what we're gonna use to replace
orthogonal projection with so it's a it
could still be hard it could still be
hard you're trying to find essentially a
root of a hyperbolic polynomial one of
the roots the one that's on the boundary
giving you the point on the boundary but
it's a one-dimensional line search so
you can be a very high dimensional space
and the problem with finding this
intersection is a one-dimensional
problem so that's a lot different than
trying to do an orthogonal projection
projection when you're in a high
dimensional space to a difficult object
okay hypervelocity cones hyperbolic
programming there's our hyperbolic
programming problem same hyperbola
Sudoku and it fits perfectly within
first-order methods it's got an
objective function that is smooth smooth
can be I mean they got the same gradient
every place how nice it can be but again
you know what's the algorithm say a
first-order method says well subtract
the gradient of the objective from your
current interet some multiple always
going to subtract some multiple oh see
that's very naive algorithm then project
onto the feasible region you'll get an
algorithm by doing this they converge
this but of course it's it's nonsense
okay so how can we get around this so
now we're gonna put another condition on
e so before E was just in the interior
of the hypervelocity cone now we're
going to assume that it also satisfies
the equations so this is an assumption a
fairly big assumption and somehow you
have to get around it I'm not going
to that today but you can but the
assumption we're really making is that
we know a strictly feasible point II so
any point the hypervelocity code gives
you a direction of hypervelocity you can
take any one of them and so but now we
have also a you want we want Eve to
satisfy a equal to B so we know a
strictly feasible point we'd also like
to be far away from the boundary of the
hypervelocity cone to control the
Lipschitz constant but assume the
hyperbolic program has an optimal
solution we're going to replace the
problem up here with a different problem
we're going to replace it with this
problem so this is a concave function
again minimum eigen value function we're
going to maximize it subject to the same
constraints as I have for the hyperbolic
the same equation plus one more equation
the restriction is that this this is a
fixed constant Z now C Z has to be less
than the objective value at my pointy
what you what you know e we know is
strictly feasible point and you can
choose any Z that's less than this and
what I'm going to tell you the next
slides will be true so this is going to
be a problem we we're going to be
looking at from the point of first order
methods this is nice I mean our feasible
region now is just an affine space and
so projecting onto an affine space is
easy especially if there aren't too many
equations and it's the same affine space
at every iteration so you can do some
pre-processing to build the the null
space matrix or to do a projection onto
the null space of the matrix a with
so it's it's a nice you know compared to
trying to do projections up here onto
that set bezel region this is this is
very nice
the claim is that the optimal solution
to this once I once I get that optimal
solution then by taking its radial
projection you know going towards E and
then where I find that hit the boundary
its radial projection will actually be
optimal for the hyperbolic program
Lipschitz continuous function this is
not smooth typically just like it's not
for symmetric matrices so we can't we
don't have a smooth function we can't
apply it accelerated gradient method to
it but we can certainly apply a sub
gradient method to it and we're not
going to be stopped by having to do some
kind of crazy orthogonal projection I
will explain it in pictures so hey I've
got my constraints we've got X in some
high dimensional space but for
simplicity suppose that the affine space
you get from ax equal to B is two
dimensional high dimensional space
here's the two dimensional affine space
so this is what these would all be
feasible points but now I've got X's and
K so the cone K slices through that
space so the feasible region is this now
this two-dimensional set we're so mean
that we know a point E that's in the
interior of the cone and that satisfies
the linear equation constraints a X
equal to B so there's our point E it
lies in the plane
we're simplicity we'll assume that the
objective function is constant on
horizontal slices and we'll assume that
it gets better as you go down we'll
assume the optimal solution is here and
so now what I'm going to do is choose
fix one of these who are these slices
that's what I do when I introduce a new
constraint see X equal to Z and Z has to
be less than the objective value at E so
we're gonna fix one of these slices it
could be a slice down here here anywhere
down don't read anything into it I'm
gonna discuss show them to fix a slice
it actually goes through the feasible
region this is the slice this is this
will be the constraint set for that
equivalent problem when I claim to be an
equivalent problem you're trying to
maximize the minimum eigen value subject
to these linear equations so you're
working these are your only constraints
that problem it only sees this slice
this slice space right slice paces of
course satisfies ax will go to B but it
also satisfies this additional equation
one dimension and so what we're gonna do
we're end up going to end up trying to
maximize them in a Mayan value subject
to being in that set game but before we
do that let's think about what's going
on for points in that set so for each X
it has a projection onto the boundary
okay line from X through E where does it
intersect the boundary including if X is
outside the cone you're projecting
backwards okay and someone gets mapped
down to the optimal solution its radial
projection is the optimal solution and
so what the claim was that I was making
is that this is exactly the point which
minimum maximizes the minimum eigen
value on this slice
the claim okay so let's see why that's
true so the claim is if I can compute
that point well it's obvious like it can
be at that point I would be done but the
claim is at that point is the optimal
solution that gives you the point which
on that slice maximizes the minimizing
value why is it true in this case I'm
not gonna pull out of my discussion here
you can ask me again okay so this now
let me let me just argue that that
really is the the point on that space
which actually does maximize the minimum
eigen value okay so all we do for this
is let's require the formula here was
the formula for the radio projection and
so let's just look at what the objective
value is for the radial projection so
here's the objective value I've just
plugged in this and 2 C times pi X and
so then here's the the crucial
observation we're working on a slice
this quantity right here is fixed as Z
so this difference because Z is less
than this this is a negative constant so
I'm trying to find a point on the slice
which will make this as big as possible
because I want to take advantage of that
being negative so I want to make this as
large as possible so I want the minimum
eigen value to be as large as possible
as close to one as possible to make this
ratio be as large as possible and so the
point on the slice which then maximizes
this minimum eigen value is going to
make this denominator as small as
possible make this ratio as large as
possible take advantage of this being a
negative constant and so consequently
that is the point which will give you
the boundary point the pie X point which
actually is the optimal solution
you're gonna be trying to minimize see
high of X you're thinking of this X is
coming from this affine space and so
it's the X which actually maximizes the
minimum eigen value which is going to
make this as small as possible so in a
sense what we're doing is we're building
up a map of the boundary we're on a flat
space every X is being identified with
its radial projection and then you have
this formula you know for what the
radial projection is and then plugging
in you can argue that well the point you
want on that slice on that at a plane
space that slice is the point that
maximizes the minimum eigen value that
is the point that's going to get
projected to the guy which has this beam
as small as possible all right okay so
what we have now is we have an
equivalence we have our hyperbolic
program we have this eigenvalue
optimization program so it's sort of
interesting even in the case of SDP it's
long been known that eigenvalue
optimization is a special case of SDP
but what this is also saying is that if
you happen to know a strictly feasible
point ya identity matrix if you're lucky
a strictly feasible point then in fact
you can turn any any semi definite
programming problem into an eigenvalue
optimization problem and so in some
sense they're equivalent but that also
extends it extends to hyperbolic program
in fact extends to convex programs in
general conic programs in general but
I'm not going to go there today
it wasn't no it was not yeah no I mean
it's very simple right but no yeah no I
knew it wasn't when I asked Nesterov and
he said I've never seen that but no it
hasn't I've been talking about it for
years now and yeah go figure okay so
what we have now you know we have this
nice optimization problem we can play
first-order methods to it and we have
bounds right but what the bounds are is
they're telling us this is the objective
function for that that problem and you
know it's not this we're not really
interested in trying to maximize the
minimum eigen value this is just a means
to an end and really what we're trying
to watch is to get a X it's feasible for
which CX is close to optimal and so now
relying on that you know we have this
algorithm where now we we're going to
apply the sub gradient method to that
objective function with those linear
equations now we want to get an
algorithm for saying something about the
hyperbolic program there's one little
kind of catch in it which requires an
algorithm which doesn't just choose one
slice and apply it to one slice but has
to be a little bit more judicious and
let me just give you a picture to show
you why suppose your slice is very close
to e and so then what you're relying on
is radio projections you can now have
two points that are pretty close
together up here good approximations but
when you project them down they spread
out you distort the geometry and so this
makes it important that you don't just
fix any an easy it'd be great if you
chose a Z you chose that slice to be
down below where the optimal solution
occurs but you don't know where the
optimal solution occurs going in to
solve a problem if you happen to choose
a Z that is close to e and you just
apply a first order method it turns out
it can take a lot of iterations because
yeah to get really close to getting
something that'll project down close to
the optimal solution so I won't go into
it but what we do is we assume that you
have an initial feasible point for the
hyperbolic program whose value is less
than the value at E we apply the sub
gradient method on that slice until it
gets far enough in satisfies a certain
criteria that it's minimizing values
fairly large and then it does a
projection to move down to a new level
he's doing this in this way it gets away
from from E if it happened to start
close to e and right and so in
first-order methods
you always have distance to the optimal
solution showing up so as a surrogate
for distance to the optimal solution on
any slice the distance to where the max
minimum eigen values maximize we just
take the diameter and we assume that the
diameters all these diameters are
bounded so it's sort of saying that it's
not a poorly conditioned conic
optimization problem as yeah so here's
the result that comes out you do get a
bound so you're gonna get within epsilon
now look at this this is unlike the
first order method but this projection
is it's going to force you to do is
rather than saying I'm going to get
within epsilon of the optimum value the
radial projection forces things to
become you have to talk relatively in
the denominator there is your initial
point right that's your initial point
there is the optimal value that's for
your hyperbolic program and so you're
measuring progress relative to what your
initial gap was you don't know z star
this is just this just comes out and so
it says after this many iterations again
it's a sub gradient method so you have
to keep track of the smallest XK you've
seen so far you look at the radial
projections and the track of the XK for
which the radio projection has given you
the smallest value of objective for the
hyperbolic program you've seen so far
and says within
this number of iterations and you
actually do get within relative error
epsilon so things now have shifted over
to relative error you do get the epsilon
squared okay so that's just coming from
some gradient methods this is coming
from the fact that the ball the largest
ball you could even ball centered it E
if it's in the cone is giving you a
Lipschitz constant for your lambda min
function diameter and so forth so the
interesting thing here is one over
epsilon squared you get an algorithm
that I won't get this is just measuring
how close far you were this you know
this is big number if you started out
with a slice really close to e so this
is just putting it inside the logarithm
so that doesn't really hurt you in the
long run okay but it's the epsilon
squared
this will be suet let them in big one or
bigger than one
no because yeah yeah we made the
assumption that
sdp are the hyperbolic program has an
optimal solution so in yeah this slice
all of these will have minimum eigen
value strictly less than 1 right and you
can you can see that because you go from
e towards anything in the slice and
you're going to hit the boundary at some
point once you assume that there's
nozzles
all right smoothing how'd you get better
bounce okay and so this is where you
really rely on structure of no meals and
so Nesterov looked at this in the case
of SDP and so I just used Helton Vinnie
Cobb to leverage what he did and I did a
few other things so what you do is this
is a function so here are your eigen
values for your point X again E is fixed
it looks potentially like this may not
be such a nice function because in the
eigen values do not vary continuously
and are differentially in X as X changes
if you have multiple roots for example
okay but it is nice in the sense that
you can see that it's an approximation
it's giving you approximation to the
minimum eigen value function and so
depending on the parameter mu you choose
you get a under and over approximation
using mu and so for example if you
choose mu to be this quantity right here
then you can say that the value of mu of
X is within epsilon over 2 of the eigen
value at X what's nice about this
function it's actually analytic not only
differentiable its analytic it's smooth
and it's its gradient marries nicely and
the infinity norm and the dual of the
infinity norm the gradient is Lipschitz
with this know whatever mu is a constant
again this is comes from nest Robin the
FTP case and then hammering at it with
help in ACOG and there's an old analysis
result to get the and so the corollary
you needed all in terms of the Euclidean
norm and so your Lipschitz cost and the
Euclidean norm comes out to be for your
gradient map it's now our of e square
and yes gradients
okay so it's very nice setup for
applying accelerated methods you don't
know of course you don't know what how
close point is he is to the boundary so
you don't know what this Lipschitz
constant is first-order methods
typically rely on an approximation to
the Lipschitz constant so in this next
result what I do is I rely on what's
called a universal method my Nesterov
who else which you give it a guess of
the Lipschitz constant and it it it
alters the Lipschitz constant over time
finds out when it needs to alter it and
made a wrong guess and finally get
something that's appropriately close
here's the kind of bound you get it's
the same setup as previously it's a
little bit more sophisticated because I
wrote this paper half year later and I'd
figured out how to make things a little
bit nicer but now you get the one over
epsilon again it's relative you so
you're gonna get an XK you're working on
a slice you're doing its radial
projections after a while when you take
the Radio projection you'll be
guaranteed that this ultimate error
epsilon and this gives you gives you the
bound there's nothing on epsilon over
here other things including this is a
guess on the Lipschitz cost that you
start with the actual Lipschitz constant
the dependence is only logarithm on how
bad your guess is you do have M now
showing up you do have n showing up
because you chose M the MU your new
vector it's logarithmic in in
and so the paper also one spent a lot of
time showing how to compute the the
gradients of f4u efficiently assuming
that you can compute the gradients of
your LP okay I've got a little bit more
to say okay so that's you know so that's
well we walked through now as we did the
we did the sub gradient method that gave
us a 1 over epsilon squared then we did
this approach with Nesterov the
smoothing okay with the smoothing you
lost some and the approximation you no
longer have the minimum eigen value in
hand you're not computing that you're
computing the value of the smooth
function and its gradient ok so you've
lost a little bit an accuracy then but
then you're able to then apply nest ROVs
accelerated method in the end you don't
get a square root of epsilon you get a 1
over epsilon and that's because the wave
chosen your your mu is dependent on
epsilon and so for the Lipschitz
constant you end up with a 1 over square
root of epsilon R 1 over epsilon gets a
square root and then on the end you get
actually an epsilon down here it's again
you're not starting with a smooth
problem you smooth but you've done
better than you would with the sub
gradient method ok so let me give you
sort of where I'm thinking now is now
I'm not so convinced that this is the
way to go with hyperbolic programs so I
think their arguments for doing
subgradient methods so let me stay the
same method so let me end with that ok
for one thing this function the
smoothing function it requires computing
an eigen decomposition of your matrix X
if you're in the case of semi definite
programming
and so this this is actually what the
gradient would be coming out to look
like assuming you're using the trace
inner product and so by contrast if you
just look at the minimum eigen value
function itself which is non smooth to
compute a sub gradient all you need to
do is get hold of an eigen vector are a
good approximation to an eigenvector for
the minimum eigen value so you don't
need the full spectrum of eigenvectors
you don't need north normal basis okay
so already your you know that's great
because you can try something like a
power method where you just multiply a
vector over and over again by the matrix
especially if you have sparsity
constraints in your semi definite
programming problem that goes very fast
much faster than trying to compute an
eigen decomposition and then creating
this matrix so that's that's an argument
for the or the Sun gradient method
another thing which is you know points
to the fact that you know SDPs
all of them aren't nasty if you look at
generic sets they have unique solutions
unique optimal solutions and here's what
I want to focus on particular that their
growth and their objective function as
you move away from the optimal solution
set you look at feasible X and you start
moving away from the optimal say a
unique optimal solution at least for a
while the objective value will increase
quadratically in the distance away from
the optimal solution you have a
quadratic okay so that's nice okay and
so it's been known for a long time and
from this now the problem we're
interested in is this been a meygan
value problem the case of SDP this
translates then that this function to
when you look on the feasible region and
you move away from the optimal solution
set this function also will grow
quadratically wait
he said now let's step all the way back
to the beginning where we started okay
we're gonna think in a minute about F as
being a function where it grows
quadratically and I'm gonna so this is
gonna be a very general theorem really
that I'm stating here it doesn't have to
do with hyperbolic programming here's
the algorithm we relied on the sub
gradient method with this step size well
we wanted to get accuracy Epsilon and
minimizing F okay and then that led us
to a bound which depended like 1 over
epsilon squared to get within epsilon of
the optimal value you look at this and
you say okay this is stupid you know
you're trying to get something really
small you're taking really small steps
so of course it's gonna take you a long
time to get towards optimality so then
here's a simple idea rather than fixing
epsilon why don't we think of very
various different sub gradients all
running simultaneously in parallel so
one with epsilon 1 with 2 times epsilon
1 with 4 times epsilon 1 with 8 times
Epsilon and so forth until we get up to
something 2 to the N where 2 to the n
times epsilon is approximately equal to
1 ok ok so there'll be one of those sub
gradient methods in there that's taken
really long steps and there'll be the 1
the farthest one down taking really
little steps one with really going with
really long steps if you're far away
from optimality it'll make great
progress ok but once it gets close to
optimality and just start swinging all
around optimality without actually
moving in ok but at that point then
somebody with making smaller steps can
move in so you have to have the
algorithms communicate with each other
and I don't have time to go through this
but it's a schematic for approach a
scheme that we came up with it actually
applies a lot more general than the sub
gradient method where you run these
algorithms in parallel you don't have to
know virtually anything you don't know
the optimal value but it's all based on
these algorithms having a certain goal
and once they meet the goal then they
tell the algorithm below it making their
small
steps look you might want to move to
this point I know you're taking really
small steps look this was better might
be a better point for you and so they
compared
sorry baron thank you
you just I just move reached up to them
yeah so I got all these algorithms what
I seen here so they're operating in a
high dimensional space and but what you
know is their function values their
current function values so this is a
real number like this tells you for
they're all starting at the same point
they all had the same objective value
they all then set a goal the one taking
the smallest step says I want to get at
least this improvement in objective
value next one up says I want to get
that improvement and so forth
okay and so then they all take a step
and so no one has reached their goal at
this stage and then finally this one
reaches its goal once it's reached its
goal what it does it takes the point
that it's reached this goal and it tells
the next algorithm down about that point
okay so it's gonna send it to that
algorithm and then it resets its goal
and then everybody starts taking a new
step and then and then this point is
finally communicated to the next
algorithm it takes time to get there
this algorithm has actually achieved its
goal but just now has this it says uh
I'd rather start there instead and so
it's just a way of rather you don't know
what your output value is you don't know
how far you have to go but you do know
how much progress you've made and so
it's just based on that idea and it
works it actually works and it actually
speeds up accelerated methods too and so
in this case if you have quadratic
growth what you get is you don't get one
over epsilon squared number of
iterations you get one over epsilon log
win over epsilon the log 1 over epsilon
iterations it's subgradient evaluations
log win over epsilon is coming from
having log win over epsilon some
gradient methods in parallel and so the
point here is that by this symmetric by
this parallel sub gradient method I get
a bound which is very close in some
sense to the one over epsilon bound I
got by smoothing there's a lot being
hidden in the constant here it's
depending on how fast things grow
quadratically and also remember the sub
gradient method computing a sub gradient
is simple you have to compute the
smallest eigen vector you don't have to
do a full eigen decomposition okay and
so which way is better
I don't know you know I know I have
enough but my last slide my last love my
same approach okay you do the same
approach and you do it for polyhedral
cones okay for polyhedral cones then you
have what's called linear growth away
from your optimal solution set you can
say that for any feasible point whether
exist a vector this should be just a
three there exists no meigan value as it
has linear growth it'll actually be a
piecewise linear function concave linear
function and right and and the growth is
dependent linearly on the distance to
the optimal set okay with that what you
actually getting yet by doing this
parallel thing is you get a number of
sub gradient evaluations which depends
on log 1 over epsilon squared and so
it's not 1 over epsilon like you do for
the smoothing and so what this makes
apparent is that you know doing
smoothing in the case of a linear
program is total nuts because you have
you end up having to do more computation
than you have to with a sub gradient
method and every iteration and besides
going with the sub gradient method has a
potential of getting you there much
faster where you want to be
[Applause]
okay very quick boarding so you the
library used to be a physical building
okay
so anybody who has not been to the
mathematics library at their University
you invited drastically beside the
mathematics lighter yes yeah it depends
this is what I'm hiding this is so this
is this comes in the Big O depends on
this is what's bad it's this growth this
growth can actually be quite small right
and so in something like an interior
point method you would always be getting
the log win over epsilon and you would
also in something like this when you go
to be getting like a log 1 over mu
whereas here you're going to be getting
a 1 over mu for a first order medicine
yeah it definitely shows up particularly
1 over mu squared yes definitely shows
up
okay second group anybody who does not
know what punch cards are everybody else
any questions
yes so what do you do this leaf
formulation with a linear program and
you will reformulate the linear
programming to this eigenvalue yeah I
mean it does fine I mean it's not gonna
it's not gonna compete with simplex when
you're working on problems of scale the
simplex method can handle it's all
getting become of interest once you go
way beyond where you know carrying
around so in the simplex method you have
to have that basis inverse it gets
updated every iteration and so if you
have lots of equations you have em very
large and half as many equations if you
have number of variables then you're
carrying around a fairly large matrix
it's getting updated every iteration so
that's the bottleneck for scaling
whereas this is not going to require
that in the case of linear programming
where you have the non-negative or that
and your E is the vector of all ones
then what the objective the minimum
eigen value turns into is you're just
looking at the minimum coordinate of X
[Applause]
do you have a vision yeah yeah no yeah
no then this is a paper so it's it's
it's yeah it's hold Aryan growth it's
always done in two whole daring growth
and it's examples very several
first-order methods the the proof is
very general though and it's not a deep
[Applause]
office at 2:15 and if you're local maybe
raise your hand follow the locals you
know to lunch